hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
ai is encroaching on many fields that
are traditionally run by humans
so far it's been mostly technical tasks
recognizing ct scans for doctors
predicting oil deposits for engineers
image recognition tasks and things of
that sort but art is something different
and it's one of the last fields to be
encroached upon
art takes a unique combination of skill
creativity and the very human element of
aesthetic taste
but what if i told you that for the
first time it looks like the visual art
may have also fallen to ai
you all may have heard of the artificial
intelligence research group openai
in april of 2022 they released something
special it's a very powerful
text-to-image generator that can draw
virtually anything you want
this has been done before but the real
difference here is that the results will
almost always be artistically pleasing
by design with correct colors and
features that look like the creative
judgments of a real artist
in this episode we'll see exactly what
it can do how it works and what it means
for the world this is going to be an
interesting one let's get into it
[Music]
[Music]
so what is it
the new ai system is called dali 2 and
is capable of turning any text
description into a unique image or work
of art that has never been seen before
the technology is based on the gpt-3
text generation system which we've
talked about before
dali 2 is an updated version of dali
which we covered last year
the original daley was limited it could
only render images from text prompts in
a cartoonish manner
in contrast the new dali 2 system
generates high quality high resolution
images complete with complex backgrounds
depth of field effects realistic shadows
shading and reflections
the resolution is also higher
it also does its job much quicker only
taking about 10 seconds to generate
images it also includes new capabilities
like editing an existing image
so enough chatting let's see what it can
do
here we have the instagram artist karen
chang putting it through its
walking paces a staircase 10 seconds and
then it'll generate an image that's
brand new
[Music]
okay okay okay
that's pretty good um let me try
a girl walking up an infinity staircase
whoa
oh my god
these are beautiful
uh what kind of finished staircase made
of cookies in the clouds
[Music]
oh my god
[Applause]
look at this cookie staircase
yo this is like
the stuff of dreams yo
[Music]
so far some of you might be thinking so
what it's just smashing random images
together but as we'll see it's nothing
like that when you think about what's
going on here in a fundamental level
it's simply astounding
let's study a few examples to see what i
mean
look at this example of a dolphin in a
spacesuit
how did dali 2 know that that's how a
spacesuit on a dolphin would look like
why did it choose that pose
why is the lighting coming from that
particular direction why does the planet
have those particular colors
if you really think about it these are
generally the kind of decisions that an
artist would make
in this next example the prompt was to
make a napoleon cat holding cheese
again why did the system choose this
particular pose
how did it know that these colours would
work well in the scene look closely at
the details in the crease of the suit
and pants it all looks like it was
thoughtfully composed
in fact if you were the manager at a
cheese company you would pay an artist a
good amount of money to come up with a
concept like this for a poster in the
future this could be no more a user
could just type in a sentence and there
you go an instantly engaging
advertisement
the open ai team wrote about this
concept and called it filling in the
blanks
quote unlike a 3d rendering engine whose
inputs must be specified unambiguously
and in complete detail dali is often
able to fill in the blanks when the
caption implies that the image must
contain a certain detail that is not
explicitly stated
end quote this is significant because
uncertainty isn't something that
computers are traditionally good at
take a look at the rendering of this
front garden it looks almost as good as
a photo
let's take a look at some more examples
[Music]
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
she
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
of course serious artists may find this
lacking but for prototyping and concept
art this kind of power is immense
and just to see how far this has come
here is dali too compared with the
state-of-the-art ai just a year ago
sometimes the other ais can do it well
but a lot of the time the images seem
kind of muddled dali 2 in comparison
just seems more well thought out
i think you're probably starting to see
how big this is now
a lot of artists on twitter are starting
to show some concern
[Music]
so how does this work it just has to be
pulling from a data set somewhere and
just smashing objects together right
well no
as you saw you can type anything and it
will create it there are no specific
data sets of raccoons in space or
astronauts riding horses
there's no way that it's pulling from
data that's predefined in order to
generate these images the ai has to
mimic something akin to creativity and
come up with something original so how
does it do this
well it uses two main technologies built
by open ai the first is clip a computer
vision system and the second is gpt3 the
language model that can understand and
respond to human text as we've covered
in other episodes it can have
conversations understand context and
compose long passages of original text
it can even read and summarize
information for you
since we've already covered gpt3 at
length let's take a look at the first
component
clip stands for contrastive language
image pre-training the main idea behind
clip is to pre-train a natural language
model and an image classification model
simultaneously
it does this by using a lot of labelled
images that were extracted from the
internet
the clip system was able to look at a
given image and describe its contents in
a way that humans can understand
the open ai team essentially reversed
that process
instead of looking at an image and
describing its contents a user would
describe the contents and the ai would
build it
dali 2 actually generates the image
using a process called diffusion which
has been described by the company as
starting with a bag of dots and then
filling in a pattern with greater and
greater detail
diffusion is the hottest new method of
ai generation and can be a whole nother
topic for another day
but in order to save time let's move on
to something that i find a lot more
interesting the mimicking of human
preference
in order for the image outputs to be
pleasing to humans the open ai team
simply just modeled what humans would
find pleasing and integrated it into the
training process
they call this automated aesthetic
quality evaluations
to do this they generated 512 artistic
captions using gpt-3 next they trained
the system to predict human aesthetic
judgment
to do this they used the ava dataset
which is a large body of hand-labeled
video data
once trained the ai will output
resulting images that should always look
aesthetically pleasing to humans
to me it seems like this extra layer of
mimicking what humans would find
pleasing is making all the difference
so why stop there on this channel we've
already seen ai induce motion in still
images before so
why not add another layer that turns
these images into short video animations
in fact when you think about it the
possibilities with a system like this
are almost endless
so when saying all of this dali 2 is far
from perfect though sometimes it just
gets things plain wrong
give it the instruction a red cube on
top of a blue cube and will sometimes
mix up the order
okay so the comment section must be
exploding right now a lot of people
would have this next question on their
mind what about nefarious users couldn't
someone use this system to make a fake
photo of a famous person doing a
criminal act or produce generally
unsavory material
while open ai has thought of this and
has implemented some built-in safeguards
the model was trained on data that had
objectional material removed so there's
a good chance that the system would
struggle to produce anything
objectionable anyway
users are banned from uploading or
generating images that are quote not
g-rated and quote could cause harm
nudity obscene gestures or quote events
related to major ongoing political
events are all banned
additionally the system actively
prevents users from creating pictures
based on specific names
so images of celebrities public figures
and political leaders should be
impossible
open ai research scientist prafulla
dariwal states quote our hope is to keep
doing a staged process here so we can
keep evaluating from the feedback we get
on how to release this technology safely
understandably dali 2 is an extremely
powerful technology
so open ai is only sharing the software
with what it describes as a select
screened group of beta testers
even though open ai isn't releasing the
model to the public developers can look
at their technical findings in their
published papers and update their own
work
in a technical sense this makes sense
the ai research community is broadly
still trying to figure out what works
best
openai is basically telling the research
community hey we found that this method
seems to work extremely well this might
be the direction that ai research should
go in
researchers can sign up online and
preview the system
openai hopes to later make the system
available for third party apps
looking at their longer term goals alex
nicole one of the open ai researchers
who worked on the project says quote we
hope tools like this democratize the
ability for people to create whatever
they want he says that the tool could be
a useful product for designers magazine
cover designers and artists either for
use in inspiration and brainstorming or
to actually create finnish works
illya sutscova open ai's co-founder and
chief scientist said that dali 2 was an
important step towards open ai's goal of
creating artificial general intelligence
or agi
agi is a piece of software that can
achieve or exceed human performance in a
wide range of tasks
agi would need to process multi-modal
conceptual understanding being able to
associate a word with an image or a set
of images and vice versa
he states that dali 2 is an attempt to
create an ai with this sort of
understanding
for those of you who are interested and
want to tinker with dali too i'll leave
a link to the wait list in the
description below and to be clear this
episode was not sponsored
[Music]
so in conclusion only about five years
ago the idea that an ai could create art
from scratch was radical at that time
when we looked at it on this channel
most of you and me were both very
impressed but since then the technology
has absolutely skyrocketed it's no
longer a cute novelty it's grown up into
something that's starting to catch
people off guard in the following year
it will be twice as good and then the
year after four times as good soon when
we see custom animations generated only
by a text prompt people's minds will be
blown once again
right now and in the future we'll be
asking ourselves will this technology
make artists more powerful or will it
slowly chip away at their domain in fact
what is art is this still art if all the
human involvement during the creative
process is no more if the human creative
process is gone and a machine can mimic
it just as well what is true creativity
anyway
it's enough to make your head spin but
i'm gonna pass it off to you for now how
does this make you feel do you think
that this development is something
really interesting do you see spots of
opportunity or are you completely
terrified by this feel free to leave a
comment below i'd be interested to see
how your opinions range
so thanks for watching my name is dagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion if
you want to see anything else on science
technology business or history feel free
to look around on the channel i'll also
leave my ai playlist to learn more about
the insane progress being made behind
the scenes
also thanks to all of you who checked
out my new album on spotify when i
mentioned it in the end of the last
episode it means a lot anyway i'll catch
you again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
cold fusion
it's new thinking